when do you hit the bid when do you pull
the trigger when is Charlie Evans say
we'd be able to raise the rate this
meeting we're looking at an April
meeting we're looking at June meeting
you know one thing for all the you know
students in the audience in a world of
finance there's sort of you know fair
value pricing what are you know you know
what's the stock value is supposed to be
and then there's what it actually is and
sometimes it takes a time period to get
there either going up or coming down
what I have you know my assessment of
appropriate monetary policy is that
given the economy and what we're looking
at it would be to rate hikes this year
it's not really critical when those two
rate hikes take place I guess I would
sort of say you know one in the middle
of the year one at the end of the year
could it move earlier could it move
later could you get another one in there
it depends on the data if we get a
stronger employment report if
unemployment falls continues to fall and
inflation picks up then we could get
that but april june july but witness he
just said the middle of the year that's
june so we're going to take that as a
more likely that it's jim in april well
that was you know if you have to you
know another time path would be
September in December or it could be any
particular meeting it doesn't have to be
a press conference but my goodness the
chair does a good job explaining what we
do when she has a press conference so
it's a opportunity if that's what you're
going to do your forecasting two to two
and a half percent gdp growth is this
year and that would be in line with last
year's two percent but you'll economy
only grew and one-point-four percent in
the fourth quarter and then we got a big
consumer spending report this week
january and februari numbers
weaker-than-expected consumer spending
very important so much so that the
Atlanta Fed cut its gdp forecast from
one-point-four percent to 0.6 for the
first quarter a lot of people are saying
you're looking at one percent the first
quarter president Evans what's the risk
to your forecast if the economy falls
short and doesn't accelerate for you
will you argue for a lower funds rate
path for a longer period of time or a
more aggressive more aggressive approach
well for my own outlook the numbers that
you decided don't really push that
outlook
very much I do I would say that the
consumer is a strong fundamental for
growth this year yes it does look like
the most recent retail sales and monthly
consumer expenditures have been a little
bit weak we tend to think that's
transitory though the Atlanta Fed number
that you mentioned is their GDP now
forecast which is a purely statistical
forecasts takes all the data that's a
good you know piece of information to be
looking at but judgmental information
and thoughtfulness you know could easily
push you to be a little more optimistic
about that but I'm you know more
optimistic about the middle of the year
second quarter and and beyond that even
if the first quarter is Lowell week well
I've already got only two rate increases
or I don't really have a lot to judge
you know that's already got a lot of
accommodation what's going to be at the
info if we start the year at one percent
and you're looking for two and two and
half percent four-year do we have to
have at least one three percent quarter
well we'd have to have above yeah yeah
but you know that's that's right that's
right so I mean we're going to beginning
by the middle of the year more
information that's why I kind of focused
a little more of the attention on you
know the middle of the year if the
inflation data which most recently a
couple of months have been firmer if
that continues to hold then there might
be greater reason to have confidence
that it's sustainable at a higher level
I kind of worry about that but sure it's
all part of looking at the data what's
your view on negative interest rates the
Fed has discussed and pretty much
rejected them as the Bank of Japan took
a major step in that direction and
recently the ECB followed suit what is
the alternative if for some reason
growth doesn't accelerate the economy
remains at something like a stall speed
and looks like it could even head lower
would you would you then look for
negative rates for the u.s. so it's
definitely the case that if you look
around the world as you mentioned the
Bank of Japan the ECB Swiss National
Bank the Riksbank they have been working
very hard to overcome disinflationary
trends
and to get inflation up to their
objective they've provided accommodative
policies and in many cases well in all
those cases they actually have been
charging negative interest rates no I
think you want to look at this and say
we don't want to be in this situation I
have said for the last many years that
one reason to keep our eye on the two
percent inflation objective is to make
sure we get up to two percent because if
you under run two percent and then you
find yourself at this lower level then
the economy stalls well Japan has been
in that situation for the last 20 years
and we've known you don't want to repeat
that